I can talk about a failed supernova explosion,
which has resulted in a weird white dwarf heading out into the depths of it.
Okay. So a paper came out on the 20th.
Um, so relatively recently, here it is SDSs.
And then the long telephone number that tells you what the star is,
the partially burned remnant of a low mass white Wolf.
That underwent thermonuclear ignition question Mark.
So I think we need to back up a little bit and talk about,
so this is a white door star, uh,
and it's associated with a particular type of supernova,
a thing called a type one, a supernova, very famous type of supernova,
because it's used as a standard candle. Something which the same brightness,
wherever you see it.
So it's used for cosmology where we can actually use it and figure out how far
things are away from how bright it appears.
The reason why it's a standard candle is because of the mode,
the way in which it explodes.
And essentially what happens is you have a white dwarf,
which is a very compact star.
It's held up only by the pressure of quantum mechanics effectively. The,
always the question where the star is,
why it doesn't just collapse under its own gravity.
When it's burning nuclear processes in its core that provides the energy source
that keeps it up.
But at the end of its life that goes away and the star will collapse.
And so for example,
for a white dwarf it'll collapse right down to something about the size of the
earth at that point,
these weird quantum mechanical effects kick in and stop it collapsing any
further.
But what can then happen is there is a maximum mass for which that effect will
work thing called the Chandrasekhar mass.
And if you keep adding in some way more and more mass to the star,
eventually you're going to approach that mass.
And there's a danger that the thing will collapse further and actually all sorts
of turmoil occur within the white Thor star. It'll become very convective.
It'll become very disturbed inside.
That's the point at which white dwarf is in danger of actually exploding by
firing off a whole bunch of new nuclear thermonuclear processes,
but in a very uncontrolled way. And so it will essentially explode.
Interestingly.
The views on this have changed.
It used to be thought that when a star tipped over that magical Chandrasekhar
mass,
that was the point at which you blew up as a supernova is now thought it never
quite gets to that mass, but as it approaches that mass, as I say,
it becomes very disturbed, stirs up,
very energetic processes can start happening and something then kicks off these
nuclear explosions within it. So then the question is, what will,
why would a star be putting on weight? Why where's its extra mass coming from?
And in order for that to happen,
there has to be another star nearby to kind of donate the extra mass.
And so it's probably in systems where there's a binary, you've got two SIS,
two stars orbiting each other,
and one of them is donating some of its mass to the white Wolf.
And so eventually it reaches to this point where these runaway nuclear processes
occur and it explodes.
So sort of skimming matter from its next door neighbor.
Efficiently close to it. It's actually ripping the mass off. It it's, you know,
it's it's of gravity becomes stronger than,
than the pull of gravity in the star that was holding onto that matter to start
with. So it's literally ripping off the outer layers of its,
of its neighboring store and acquiring them for itself.
Usually that process is thought to be sufficiently disruptive that there's
nothing left at the end, that the star just literally blows itself to bits. Um,
the interesting case here is that here there is still a white dwarf left, um,
but it has some weird properties and in particular,
when they studied the spectra of it.
So when they split the light up into the colors of the rainbow and looked at the
sort of signature of the different, different chemical elements,
they found some of those heavier elements that are made in the supernova
explosions.
So it looks like some sort of thermonuclear processes occurred with this white
off,
but it clearly hasn't been quite as destructive as it usually is because there's
still a white Wolf left at the end.
And the other interesting thing is that the nuclear processes haven't gone all
the way to the sort of end state that they usually do.
Usually we're not producing. You know, so the,
the carbon in the white dwarf ends up producing Silicon and Silicon turns into
Nicole and the nickel turns into wire.
There's a whole series of nuclear reactions that go on and those produce all the
elements up to iron.
The interesting thing about this white dwarf is it doesn't have those heaviest
elements in it. It doesn't have iron in it, it doesn't have nickel in it.
So it looks like the process was sort of incomplete.
It didn't destroy the star and it didn't go through all the nuclear reactions
that these things usually go through. So it's like a failed supernova.
It didn't quite fail. Clearly something pretty dramatic happened to it,
but it didn't quite go all the way. So it sort of, yeah,
it didn't quite detonate completely. It was an incomplete detonation.
The other interesting thing about it is particular star is they can measure its
speed.
You can measure the Doppler shift to tell you it's speed along the line of
sight, but actually there are also proper motion measurements for it.
They're also measurements of it's it's changing position on the sky,
so they know how fast it's going and it's actually,
it's going round the wrong way.
It's not orbiting around the Milky way in the same direction as most stars are.
And on top of that, it's going at about 200 kilometers per second.
So it's click it's going along at a pretty rapid rate,
which suggests that whatever the explosion process was gave it a pretty
big kick. So it's now traveling a high speed.
This again is a sign of something to do with probably the fact that it was in a
binary system to start with. It'd be nice to think that, you know,
it was just some failed explosion that kicked it enormously,
but it turns out that that probably isn't enough to give it the speed that we
see, but what is enough to give it?
The speed we see is if it was in a binary system and the explosion was
sufficient to unbind the binary so that the,
the two binary stars were no longer bound to each other. Because if,
for example, this was a white dwarf that was orbiting another white dwarf.
They can get very close together,
which means they're actually traveling around each other at hundreds of
kilometers per second.
And so if you then suddenly take one of these whiteboards away,
the remaining one will then just keep traveling at that several hundred
kilometers per second. So it looks like it was probably in a very tight binary,
probably with another white dwarf store.
This incomplete explosion occurred because it ripped enough of the material
from the other white dwarf to create a partial explosion.
And that disrupted the second star pop almost completely.
And so this first shot out, uh, into the Milky way.
But the one that's shot out is the one that underwent the supernova of sorts.
Yes.
Yeah. The other one was probably,
it might've been destroyed completely in the explosion just because it got
caught in the blast or it might, it might still exist.
It might itself would also be flying off in some other direction. Um,
there's really no way of telling.
So we haven't, we don't know where the, the other,
the brother is no clue at all.
So the one that's firing off that we do know about the one that's firing off
into the depths of space.
It's not just the recoil from the explosion it's to do with the kind of
uncoupling from the gravitational interaction.
Exactly.
It's almost certainly to do with the fact that you're what we're most of the
speed we're seeing is the speed that it originally had in its binary system,
but suddenly that binary doesn't exist as a binary anymore.
So it's just flying out into space.
So there's a couple of interesting implications of this one is that this type of
explosion.
So the reason why we typically see supernovae isn't because of the original
explosion it's because those explosions produce lots of radioactive material,
which then subsequently decays. And over the weeks and months that follow,
we see the energy that's being released from those nuclear decay products,
the main nuclear decay product in type one, a supernovae is nickel.
And of course this one never got round to making any nickel.
So it wouldn't have had any material to go through this decay process,
which means that if we had been around,
but the supernova almost certainly worked,
it would have been in the very distant past. But if such supernovae do go off,
you probably wouldn't see them because unless you happen to be looking at just
the right moment, when the flash occurred, then you wouldn't see it.
And then there isn't that then slow subsequent decay that would allow you to
catch the explosion later on the second sort of slight warning
here is this, you know, that the simple story we usually tell about type one,
a supernovae is they're all the same and it's very straightforward.
And that's why we can use them as standard candles.
There is at least a little bit of a warning here that says actually sometimes
weird things happen and you get incomplete explosions or different kinds of
explosions.
So it doesn't mean we have to be a little careful if we're going to be using
type one, a supernova, your standard candles.
You refer to this remnant,
that's barreling through the Milky way as a star.
Is it still acting like a star? Is it,
is it undergoing nuclear processes and emitting light? And yeah.
I mean, it's still emitting light because it's still hot, but it's, uh, it is,
it's still a white door star. So it's still held up by its degeneracy pressure.
It's not got any new nuclear processes going on, indeed.
So it's a question where do you count white doors or stars or not?
If you think of white doors to start, and this thing is still a star,
if you think it's just the remnant of a store, then I guess at this point,
it's just the remnant of a star.
Mike, if this is a common process and this happens a lot,
would we have seen them before now? Like,
should we this an oddity or is it possible? These things are everywhere.
I mean, they are relatively faint. So maybe we don't find, you know,
we don't find all of them necessarily.
And maybe we haven't studied all stars in sufficient detail.
But I think what this is probably telling us is this,
this is a kind of a rare process. And if the story I've told you is right,
that it originated in a pair of white doors that were sufficiently close to each
other. That one was actually ripping material from the other.
And at some 0.1 of them underwent our kind of slightly failed explosion.
It's probably a fairly unlikely scenario.
So I suspect there's probably not a huge number of them out there,
but we really don't know at this point.
Sounds quite exciting though. Doesn't it the idea of this, of a white dwarf,
like, you know, barreling through the Milky way,
like this sort of Cannonball run.
And sort of running from the scene of the crime as well, actually, you're right.
It's clearly, you know, that it's just survived.
This massive explosion is now heading off as fast as it can.
Did this finding excite you like to do these things still surprising?
Absolutely. In fact, so, you know, so in fact, you told me about this paper.
I didn't know about this paper,
unless you pointed me towards a newspaper article about it, uh,
which got me to read the paper. Uh, it's not why, you know,
I usually do galaxies. I don't do white doors and supernovae and things,
but the more I read about in the paper, the more interested I got in it,
because it's clear, this is a very intriguing object.
Mm mm.
Star clusters or if they were galaxies and if there are galaxies,
then that's something really,
really interesting because it's not clear how such a
dense galaxy could form, which is really, really quite nice.
It's not a very impressive image,
but this is the first image that new horizons took before.
It went on to take images of Jupiter when it flew past Jupiter and then images
of Pluto and now even images of an asteroid in the Kuiper belt as well.